welcome to this video playing the brig
II never Platon from the USS this a new
account why it's got 3,000 games and
five minute amazing yeah I'm always
amazed that you have people that are
really active on the server and I never
played them never played them yeah one
reason can be the different types of
course now i'm playing in the in the in
the afternoon which I don't do so often
okay yeah the mac had gone off I think
in it all it all indicated that he was
going for b5 so I set up against that
okay let's prepare this h4 okay
I'm a bit of a bit mystified him see we
try to play b5 not
ok
wow really even allowing Bishop g4 here
push-up g46 and stuff okay yeah well hg
wasn't also wasn't like a bed of roses
but but still okay b5 you probably will
play that quickly quickly getting to 2h7
would be nice i'm trying that to go into
h3 attacking h7 if I play this now push
up e6 takes takes 95 isn't this isn't
this quite good okay check
now all you need to take and now we
cannot take with the Queen as Queen h7s
made so he needs to needs to take and
then I take with the sea pawn and this
looks really nice i z7 ah ok then the
Queen hangs but I have I have I have
this one I have this move him check ok
yeah he's collapsing on h7 no rook takes
man takes resigns yeah well this was
somewhat somewhat cope cooperative this
this opening yeah i mean this already is
starting to be a be dangerous for black
as i get this big space and the on the
queenside and he has the queenside
totally closed I mean any counter play
with a 6b five I can stop with a four in
the game I didn't felt that I needed to
do it because this is just too quick but
yeah yeah this is this is not a playable
position I mean why it has such a huge
space advantage the idea h2h takes g6
assaults are not nice Queen 2h7 and mate
just need to to get down the Sun yeah
there should be six already was strong
but I wanted to get the the Queen and
the game channel this is check yeah of
Kuala came he must must take now but
this is it really really cool the sir
this paw information you 45 e6 and
tiered would be very cute to get this 92
g 6 cm right here something like that is
a quite quite cool yeah very nice for in
tights game but will he helped me a lot
with this opening alright thanks for
watching